did you plan what a nice coincidence
says this book is out in time for the
holidays in holiday shopping was that
something that figured into your
planning Sarah it's because I blew my
deadline but um I think it does make a
nice stocking stuffer you know and I
mean I actually like you know the like
those history books like the big door
Stoppers like I call those the books
Republican dads get for Christmas and it
turns out like Republican dads do get my
books for Christmas oh they just get
them from their lesbian daughters and
[Applause]
from their vegan son my ratings and
they'll be like some old coot in a feed
store cap and he'll be standing next to
like this middle-aged eccentric lady and
a keep Austin weird t-shirt my books
like really bring these families because
I only write I write about stuff they're
Republican dads care about yeah what I
write about in a way that their lesbian
daughters can get with that's the best
marketing ploy
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]